[Música]
en el extremo suroeste culmina francia
en medio de las olas detrás de la bahía
de anda y se encuentra españa- y este es
el punto de partida de la frontera la
isla de los faisanes 200 metros de largo
por 40 de ancho
aquí fue firmado el tratado de los
pirineos entre luís 14 y felipe cuarto
de españa en 1659 el acuerdo le puso fin
a la guerra entre los dos países tras la
firma del tratado fue necesario
materializar la frontera entre francia y
españa con mojones aún visibles hoy en
día
este es el sector de endarlatsa donde se
encuentra el mojón frontera número uno
se trata del primer límite terrestre
entre francia y españa
la frase de españa
un primer bloque de piedra instalado más
de dos siglos después de la firma del
tratado de los pirineos bajo napoleón
tercero como pudieron traerlo hasta aquí
en barco con mulas no es evidente porque
es pesado
para que ambas que cambia haya que pagar
en total hay 600 dos mojones como este
entre el atlántico y el mediterráneo y
cada uno tiene una historia por contar
empezando por el que está encaramado en
lo alto de la runa y la primera montaña
al oeste de la cadena de los pirineos
al inicio de la primavera el pequeño
tren de la runa empieza a operar de
nuevo por la temporada
dentro de poco se cumplirán 100 años
desde que esos vagones de madera lucen
turistas a 905 metros de altura a una
velocidad de crucero de 9 kilómetros por
hora
la runa es el macizo más grande al
principio de la cadena de los pirineos
la runa quiere decir buen pasto
arriba en la llegada se encuentra un
nuevo mojón que será el paso para
director de los contrabandistas en
aquella época
[Música]
como podemos ver al costado es el número
25 en aquella época los contrabandistas
decían vamos a cruzar el mojón número 25
al día siguiente cambiaban cruzaban por
el mojón número 50 tour alcohol podía
haber alcohol encaje todo lo que era
comercializable lo pasaban y lo papel
ahora esas montañas son el lugar de vida
de pastores y sus rebaños marina tiene
20 años y es pastor a perpetua la
tradición pastoral de su padre
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hoy sus ovejas van a pasar
indiferentemente entre francia y españa
sin problema pero no siempre fue así
cada agricultor que conducía su rebaño a
la runa contaba con un carnet estaba
prohibido mover el rebaño en la runa
entre la puesta del sol y el amanecer
al día siguiente esto evitaba todo lo
que era contrabando era para limitar el
contrabando y el comercio entre los
agricultores
todo ello cambió con el paso de los años
pero para mantener esta paz entre los
dos países es necesario entenderse ya
que los representantes de pueblos
fronterizos se reúnen con frecuencia
para firmar acuerdos pastorales desde el
siglo 18 una tradición muy respetada aún
en el país vasco
[Música]
y aquí estamos en la mesa de piedra
estamos en la frontera
este es el mojón frontera aquí estamos
en sage y aquí en vera de bidasoa
ha dejado minas cada cinco años
alrededor de esta mesa tiene lugar una
ceremonia institucional que no tiene
nada de folclórica el día de la firma es
alegre pero se trata de un trabajo serio
cuando un animal de navarra está enfermo
los pastores franceses avisan y hay un
buen entendimiento entre ellos más al
este
109 mejores de fronteras más allá se
encuentra una etapa más en la línea
francia y españa- el paso del ajax san
martãn aún cuenta con mucha nieve al
inicio de esta primavera
está empezando a derretirse de hecho
pero aquí estaba bien esto se ve un poco
aquí está el mojón este es 262 aquí como
en cualquier otra parte el mojón cuenta
con una historia en el siglo 14 un
conflicto entre pastores respecto a una
fuente le causó la muerte un centenar de
civiles
españoles estamos en paz con los
españoles y está bien pero otro ahora la
situación era distinta fuimos condenados
a perpetuidad a pagarles a los españoles
con tres vacas cada año ahora reciben h
que antes se llevaban las vacas pero
sigue siendo de actualidad
imposible ir más lejos para seguir el
trazado hay que esperar que los
esquiadores se vayan y que la nieve se
derrita hay 340 bajones de frontera por
descubrir a lo largo de los pirineos
antes de llegar al mediterráneo
[Música]